most people never get to chance to spend
a day in the life of a Top Gun unless
they happen to have spent several
thousand dollars on Breitling pilots
watches in chronographs I didn't know
the jet team existed until I was invited
here than I did my research and like Wow
in 2003 Swiss watchmaker Breitling
established its own jet team the largest
civilian aerobatic team as a way to pay
homage to its aviation roots riling has
a long history in the world of aviation
we start making instruments for
navigation then it becomes Henry's watch
team performs at air shows and special
events all over the world last year with
its first American tour some of it was
and the first time the company offered
some of its best customers the
opportunity to take to the skies guy
actually buy all my writings from
invited me up about a month ago
take these lucky customers got to have
their very own Mavericks moment
courtesy of brightly or spending the day
at this Connecticut hanger hanging out
with the pilots and riding shotgun and
an l-39 sea albatross as the debt team
practice barrel roll
Danish Kotak is a Breitling customer
from Toronto and he thinks being given
the chance to experience five vertical
G's of course firsthand could make him a
Breitling customer for life when they
give you the experience that you're
gonna remember for a lifetime you know
every time you look I look at my watch
I'm gonna think about this experience
and it's gonna make me wanted buy more
watches and obviously be loyal when I'm
when I actually I'm looking for a watch
and that Breitling says is exactly the
point no way branding today two
millennia it's a challenge for a lot of
company
because the the regular way of
communicating has evolved but I think
there is nothing better for education or
for discovery to live an experience
Breitling offered just two customer
flight days last year this year the team
will host eight it's a bet that a day in
the air with the jet team could boost
Breitling's tail